nfl star logan ryan won two super bowl
titles while playing with the new
england patriots success that he hopes
to replicate here in new york with the
giants
but it's his work off the field where
ryan is trying to have an even bigger
impact
earlier this year ryan helped lobby for
the george floyd justice and policing
act which aims to end racial bias in
policing
and make departments more transparent
while the bill awaits senate vote
ryan wanted to do more so he teamed up
with his dad
to take action if we help
that one cop or that one altercation or
that one civilian get home to their
family
prevent one incident in my hometown just
one then this company made a world of
difference
for two-time super bowl champion logan
ryan police reform
starts here in his hometown of berlin
new jersey
about a hundred miles south of his home
with the giants
metlife stadium anything that i wanted
to do
my dad was there for me for help with
the project ryan turned to a man with
decades of experience in law enforcement
every crime you've ever investigated
i've investigated his father lester
a retired camden police officer and
former member of the fbi
i'm for the police i was raised by a
police officer but i'm also for the
people
i protested for the people i grew up
black i'm a black father
i've been through some of those stresses
and struggles i feel like we have a
unique father-son connection
with his expertise and my platform to
sit here and say man
if i feel like i'm more than a football
player you're more than just a cop and
maybe we can make a difference
the techniques that i've learned from
that i'm going to put into the program
through their newly founded company ryan
solutions the pair
is developing a police training
curriculum they're hoping to bring
more empathy and reason to both the
officers and the communities they police
at some point your distance better be
right we visited their first training
session last month in berlin
the crux of lester ryan's method is
based on respect
if you're disrespectful to me as a
citizen
i'm not supposed to be disrespectful to
you which is easier said than done
yes that's the problem i have to sit at
a higher standard
right so if you're disrespectful to me i
still will call you sir
and i still will call you ma'am and i'll
try to connect
to you on some level of um empathy
that's all the community wants to be
retreated with respect right
it's the way you treat people that's
what they're offended at
have either one of you had an experience
with a police officer that has been a
bad experience
i definitely had situations where i felt
like
i wasn't being talked to respectfully
there was times where i felt like it
wanted to go there
growing up black my dad taught me that
i can't control what someone else may do
or may think of me
but i almost have to be better i kind of
felt like growing up getting pulled over
i had to
be the more mature person in that
situation at a young age when we go to
the right
training both ryan say is crucial logan
compares it to football
you got to keep doing the training right
muscle memory muscle memory
hundreds of thousands of reps i took to
feel comfortable in the most high
pressure situation so why in policing
we not emphasize training more and more
reps
proper reps so when you are in that
stressful situation
you do have that bad day you're in a bad
mood at work you can go over late
and perform to the level of your
training we saw today
some officers here obviously i'm sure
you'd want more
if possible how do you guys feel i'm
extremely encouraged
because today today was a concept
brought to light
he can't go everywhere and touch every
officer but if he touches one officer
that officer might
arrest how many people if we if we get
the top officers we get the chiefs to
come and they can learn a couple of our
methods
they may be able to teach a couple of
their guys because it
it's such a big problem somebody would
look at this and say that's like a
just a drop in the water it's one well
one one person can do a lot
because one drop can send out many
ripples in a pond
that can create a wave is that the hope
here
i believe we have to have a national
standard of minimum force requirement
uh in this country father and son know
one training session
isn't enough they see this as just the
start
we would love to be our methodology to
be something that has to be taken every
year
so you can be certified in it all of the
things that you talk about
i start to think and that costs money
and there's a movement now that says
defund the police
defund the police is not a good idea you
have to redirect the funding
so it goes to the proper training the
funding gives the police
less materials to work with less
manpower to work with
and therefore that may cause more
problems than actually people think it's
going to help
the ryans are working on getting their
curriculum in front of senator corey
booker with their ultimate goal
obviously to bring it to that national
level
one of the police chiefs whose
department attended the first training
session
says that the concepts here would be
effective nationwide but added that it
is hard to enforce a national training
standard
when the laws in every state are
different and i know there's a lot in
there the big thing that stood out to me
is they talked about this training
it's not enough to go to the police
academy when you're first getting into
the force
the things you learn you need to
continually go back and have refreshers
not just go to the gun range and work on
your firing of your weapon you have to
work on cuffing people
on these techniques also that they talk
about with minimal force over and over i
like what logan said that sometimes you
have to you have to
actually be take it to a higher level as
a police officer
as a police officer yeah even if the
person is treating you with disrespect
you have to be the one because you're
the professional and that's something
that really requires training
exactly right you have to be put in this
situation and understands how to behave
and respond
and and logan also said if it helps just
one person if it saves one life
it will be worth it what's the name of
their company right rast it is
ryan alternative strategy techniques i
believe is the full acronym but rast and
logan's going to use his his platform
this season
to try to bring this to light even more
and his father has more training
uh scheduled already in the new jersey
area again it's like just the start
and see where it can go from there i
love the two of them together
i love when he said my dad was always
there for me i could always talk to my
dad
just seeing that dynamic i think is an
important message for people to see
and i don't think it'll be hard to get
it in front of cory booker
yeah you anthony they're having some
conversations
right now so yeah yeah it is exactly
something you should be looking at
nicely done
glad we got to meet them